Grisha gives more or less a classical
player he he very often goes for the
initiative but he goes about it in a in
a very you know classical way we would
like a positional foundation he doesn't
take crazy risks so I expect he'll try
to you know surprise me in small ways
from the start but overall a very sound
positional player I'd say with a
tendency to get into extreme time
pressure but I assume he'll because time
pressure here is going to be really a
killer I assume he'll find a way to
adjust to that
no Fabiano's strength is first is that
he is a strong player and if you go to
more details is I think he is one of the
most interesting players in openings
nowadays
Fabiano he comes up with a lot of
novelties and the new ideas in the
openings I think that maybe time will
might be my friend it's it's difficult
to to judge I mean if you don't know how
your opponent is going to react to a new
time control or how you're going direct
to new time control but if I I think the
match will generally be very close and
if one player takes advantage I think
it'll be peak B because of better time
management I never speak say bad things
about my opponents before a pleasure
maybe afterwards but not before